hello everyone it's uh it's really nice
to see you all today and
to start with i will just like to tell
you that pine biotic was founded by a
team of biotechnologists biologists
clinicians mathematicians and computer
scientists that agreed on the critical
role big data will play in biomedical
research biotechnology and agriculture
so one of the reasons that we are
meeting uh in together uh today is that
we all agree to the fact that we we know
that big data is playing a critical role
and bioinformatics has changed and
evolved from a discipline that was not
so much of
um
utilized by the universities or by uh
organizations however its growth has
tremendously
changed the paradigm because its
application in biomedical research so
with growing data
availability and its heterogeneity and
complexity it is not sufficient to
design innovative algorithms to detect
pattern so to go from pattern to inside
people especially biologists clinicians
students technicians they need to be
empowered to work with data
independently and that's why our
founding team united behind the vision
to simplify and uh to simplify
bioinformatics that is one of the key
reasons that uh we have showcased you
the the designs and other on the portal
and the platform
so by offering hands-on learning with
really user-friendly analytical
solutions we envision more people will
be equipped for data-driven reproducible
research which solves biomedical
problems but problems in biotechnology
and agri-technical technology
agriculture and all of that
so um one of the key reasons uh we
believe in this is because uh the data
that has been growing tremendously is
not being utilized by the uh by the
faculty by the clinicians because of
lack of several of those elements that
just sunalika discussed about so our
team at pine biotech specializes in
bioinformatics and big data
project driven curriculum
that integrates into the university
curricula helping students take
advantage of the resources working with
industry experts to develop cutting edge
research projects and data data analysis
skill sets so this collaborative
specialization training helps prepare
the student and researchers for
industrial and academic jobs as well as
internship opportunities so during this
collaboration process our team uh here
at pine biotech share case studies
effective strategies that have been used
by the universities for uh with our
partner universities in the us in africa
and in india to introduce bioinformatics
to non-bioinformaticians and
non-engineering students and also to
support research projects from faculty
and students
through this research fellowship program
so today i'm going to show you glimpses
of some of those
some of those achievements with
universities and students who were able
to
come out from this training and
get
opportunities but also a pathway which
we have created utilizing these
resources
to overcome these challenges and create
an uh scientific ecosystem and a omics
logic community that actually helps each
other and facilitate all of this
together
so uh
over the last few years our team
as a team we have been able to help our
partnering universities and other
collaborators by working together taking
students
to the classroom to the real world
application from their classroom to the
real world application uh
from
learning about the basic coursework and
also applying the translational research
by using data science and biotechnology
so some of our collaborators as soon as
already mentioned uh are from different
universities across the globe so
developed these courseworks have been
developed and reviewed
in collaboration with universities where
there are leading experts in
bioinformatics
omics logic in itself is a comprehensive
and a flexible program which enables
helps
faculty to design
the program according to their need and
also help students faculty and industry
to succeed in this age of data so the
program will help you learn what you
need to know about uh
advanced scientific research
and also participate in the future of
biomedicine
learn how to mine high throughput data
and discover new insights with exercises
in r or python with coding on the t by
info platform so uh these data types
that sunalika was just mentioning so the
basic coursework that we have prepared
understanding that uh our students are
from all around the globe coming from
different
uh educational background we have
students from africa we have students
from india we have students from top
universities in india in africa and also
in the us and we also have students
coming from a background uh where the
education is not comparable with the top
universities so we have prepared the
basic coursework uh that is designed for
students who can who do not have a
background in bioinformatics and uh you
know they are they many times they do
not even have a very good background in
biology so those students who wants to
start from the very beginning very
basics and are eager to learn about data
data analysis uh so we cover topics such
as genomics transcriptomics metagenomics
and their analysis we include in these
sessions at the introductory level about
the statistical analysis methods
visualizations and introduction to all
the popular machine learning methods for
omics data analysis so students uh used
to get to learn from uh
not only up by learning about the
technology or the
tools or the algorithms but also they
will learn how to apply these algorithms
to real data sets and how do we get to
those real data sets that's a very good
question thinking from a pi perspective
from a principal investigator
perspective or from a faculty
perspective is that how do we utilize
the public data repositories and
understand the various file formats in
bioinformatics for storing analyzing and
effective uh processing of this
different types of data types so the
first uh
step towards this is the basic
introductory course work that we have
prepared and there are detailed
curriculums
for all of these data types that we go
through in our own mix logic programs
that we go through with our university
partners that i could quickly show you
uh using the web browser so let me go to
the to the web browser where we have uh
where i can show you that what we are
talking about and where this is all uh
is available so a couple of resources
think of it as two
two repositories two repositories that
we are using plus a lot of open source
uh open source uh tools and resources so
these two repositories for example this
is the portal omixlogic learn portal
where we have the courses where we have
the virtual classroom
where we have the student tracking
system where we have the research
projects all of the documentation is
available here
and the tutorials as well so this
omixlogic portal is a place for faculty
to choose
what kind of specialization they would
want to work on or they would want to
teach and if they're all if you are
already teaching a specific
specialization our team is capable of
integrating the coursework and adding
projects related to your publication for
the specialization so we can discuss
that those things over a call if you're
interested in such uh collaboration
however to utilize this from uh for
student uh learning for to utilize this
as a course work for many uh who could
uh you know really benefit from the uh
basic introduction to bioinformatics
basic introduction to ngs bioinformatics
computational biology and data science
so i think it is a lot of it it has a
lot of value for students who are
graduating now who are uh
like who
want to work on the data analysis aspect
in biomedical research so uh this is one
resource that we will go through in
detail but as as you can see there are
different tabs here from courses
programs projects research that you can
explore you can start by creating a free
login so when i click here you the first
step that it asks me is to create a free
login i can use my social media handles
i can use my own gmail password and
i can log in so this is very simple um
for anyone to start with
any student any faculty to take a look
at and then then the courses so these
are asynchronous courses that we are
going to discuss and along with this
asynchronous courses uh the practical
sessions the coding and also the expert
sessions and also the industry sessions
all of this
creates this amazing ecosystem for a
student to learn about not only to learn
about a specific subject but to
understand that what are the application
where the industry is going with it and
where should i take what are the
different steps that one should take to
excel in some of these uh areas and to
contribute so
uh going back uh we have these two
resources as i was telling you one of
these resources is the learn enormous
logic another resource is the robert
bioinformatics research platform where
which is the workbench where you can
design all these different experiments
and analyze the data and that too on a
cloud so one of the biggest advantage is
the infrastructure that it provides you
usually to crunch big data you would
require a high-end server and a lot of
investment from the university to be to
maintain that server so one of the
biggest advantage of the t-band for the
platform is that uh the reproducibility
and you can be taking uh different ways
to analyze one kind of data and also to
be able to do this on cloud from your
own
laptop from a laptop with basic minimum
requirement uh so those are some of the
things that one could be able to one one
could uh
use with uh all these resources that we
are offering through the
collaborative programs now along with
these two resources i wanted to take you
to the uh to the omixlogi program page
so as i was telling you that we have
these different curriculums where we are
so here it is so let me share this link
with you so this is omix logic programs
and these are the programs that we are
pilot that we are doing with our partner
universities uh and
thousands of students are going through
this course work so what is these the
these different different courseworks
that we have put together so for example
introduction to bioinformatics in uh
genomics omix logic genomics data
analysis here you have data science and
you here you have genomic metagenomics
so when you click on the link
you will be redirected to a page where
the entire curriculum of this program is
available so you will be able to see uh
the
the webinars that we did with for this
program which actually explains this in
a very detailed manner but you can also
take a look at the curriculum here
itself to learn that about the different
topics that would be covered that are
usually covered in these programs that
will help you to work on
applying these techniques to different
type of data sets and also the
asynchronous course work and the
tutorials that are available with it so
it encompasses live sessions uh
tutorials and also
um the
topics that we are covering uh with
project examples so we are working on
data and we are understanding about
these different topics and we are doing
a coding sessions along with that and
then we are going through the case
studies so this is a comprehensive
three-month curriculum this curriculum
is also available in one month uh one
month of version uh where we are going
through some of the important topics and
many of these are done through the
asynchronous material which is available
on the learnomics logic as you have seen
so these hyperlink these are hyperlinked
to these lessons when i when you click
you you you can go to you will go to the
direct directly to that lesson and uh
you need to
have a login for that
and i hope that you all are creating a
login for yourself to explore some of
these amazing resources
that could enable us to provide
proper uh resources for the student
community uh that we are connected with
so as i was telling you that these
resources are linked to get linked to
the link to the sessions so any faculty
who is teaching this course can utilize
all of this material and can also
untrack student progress so this is uh
similarly we have uh meta genomics
genomics very detailed curriculums uh
where the focus is about you know
learning about specific uh type of
analysis and also
uh doing uh uh and learning about uh
different types of an application for
example in the case of genomics what we
are trying to learn is about specific
application of where this uh genomic
data can help us find variants and all
of that so these programs are designed
with specific application
based outcomes and also uh project
proposals if a researcher is thinking
about applying this type of analysis to
the available data sets so that's how
these basic programs are put together so
going back to my presentation so we have
this basic coursework which is also like
available for everyone like connected to
a university through a partnership
program so if we have a mou in place
with the university and if we have a
partnership together then we have a
partnership program for students where
the basic coursework is is freely
available for students to complete and
then choose whether they would want to
go for advance analysis and choose for
mentorships and so henceforth where
they'll have to pay the fee but however
for basic course work for partner
universities we have
prepared a program which is uh which is
to help them go through very basics of
bioinformatics learn about these
different technologies and also uh get
an interest of what is going on in the
scientific community to be able to uh
take proper decisions for their
educational
career for the career and also for their
education
going for to do a masters or a phd what
to choose and all those answering all
those questions so
uh as i was telling you that this entire
process is tracked so as a mentor if you
have students who are going through this
course coursework you will be able to
see their progress you will be able to
see what their achievements are so that
is done through the omics logic profile
so once a profile helps us to learn
about each other and also to learn
about what we are doing in terms of big
data research coding where am i with my
courses where am i with my certification
where am i within the program that how
many suggestions i have completed what
is left all those can be tracked through
your profile that you create once you
create your free login
so uh similarly when you join a program
so as i was telling you that
introduction to bioinformatics uh
similarly transcriptomics infectious
disease you just join a program you get
a badge for that program and you get a
subscription to get access to all of
those so this entire process is tracked
through point systems system so when you
do something uh when you complete a
course when you run a pipeline when you
complete the lesson when you update your
profile you get achievement points so
these achievement points accumulate and
let us know about your level of
expertise so as a mentor you can see the
student and see that their activities
and the points they can they have
accumulated and through this you can
categorize students amongst different
categories based on their points that
they have accumulated throughout their
experience throughout the time the
program so that uh you so that we can
identify those students who would be
eligible to work on a really good
question on a research project utilizing
these technologies utilizing these
resources
so that's how programs are structured
and in programs you will find
courseworks coursework zoom link all of
this in a single interface where uh on
the omixlogic
learn program
program uh tab so gaining certification
getting featured and most importantly it
helps us to track the progress of every
individual so
all of this process is helpful a
scheduled program so when we are doing a
scheduled program for example in in this
example you can see we started a program
from 22nd june to 31st august where we
have a lot of live sessions where we
have these asynchronous material where
we have a communication channel with the
student so a scheduled program on learn
uh
provides an interface for the
participant and the mentor to access the
resources at one place get information
about the upcoming schedule online or
on-site sessions and the links
associated with that session that
includes uh asynchronous courses big
data pipelines data sets from ncbi or a
publication or references etc
so this entire pipeline so many students
uh in our
experience need a soft landing into this
field of bioinformatics getting started
getting introduced to the application of
bioinformatics through projects and
examples and gain access to a community
with mentorship guidance and structure
so uh independent virtual learning with
our online data science courses in
person bioinformatics workshop with
practical
examples to take straight from the
classroom to the bench university
college accreditation and certification
is also available with our partner
universities so from basic learning from
step one to learning uh through the data
sets and through project examples those
examples could be from precision
medicine those examples could be from
oncology immunology neuroscience
infectious diseases and many other life
science tech life science uh fields
where this data is being generated so
advanced training is about that and then
specialization is where you start uh
start developing an
interest about a specific area of
research and you would want to work on
that area of research so that step is
then
the project and then the showcase part
is where you have an opportunity to
showcase your uh to showcase the work
that you did for recognition to the
scientific community through symposium
through uh the the platform that uh the
international community provides and
also what uh platform that we provide so
this entire process like from uh you
know training for to the asynchronous
coursework is actually structured so
each module uh within these uh training
modules so in transcriptomics you see uh
we have a coursework detailed post book
about transcriptomics you saw that we
have a detailed coursework in
metagenomics similarly you saw this data
science so all of these are structured
and designed using five elements so
these five elements are rational and
objective
engaging activities
then uh multimedia and tutorials then
practical application and then uh the
test so quantification and tests so
these elements are consistent throughout
all the coursework that we have put
together so in each coursework with
rational and objective to set
expectations for the learning relevant
technology is listed and placed into the
biological context throughout the lesson
so different type of data data types are
are presented linked to linked those to
the logic behind each of the analysis
methods that are thoroughly described
when needed so each course contains
engagement engaging activities to make
the material easier to read through and
remember so these concept these include
concept mapping quiz uh question
analysis as well as extensive glossary
of to conceptualize and conceptualize
complex terminologies and functional
linkages that helps associate
bioinformatics analysis workflow and
their function so courses are enriched
in a lot of video and multimedia insert
that helps explain uh
some of the topics with ease due to the
um
visual interface finally the course
material
and the
is reviewed in module quizzes and tests
these are timed and tied in in with the
overall within the overall student
progress so during the course student
and the faculty will be able to see how
they made make progress throughout the
courses complete practical assignments
and performances in the quizzes so this
data is crunched to provide basis for
certification
at the end of the journey
so as i was telling you that we